OTHER LAME LINE OF ATTACK
AGAINST THIS PRESIDENT AND HIS
HOPEFUL VERY OPTIMISTIC
SUPPORTERS.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW TO REACT RIGHT
HERE ON FOX NEWS, HOWARD CURT
AND DICK MORRIS.
I'M BEEN DYING TO TALK TO ALL I
DON'T HAVE YOU GUYS TODAY ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE WHEN I STARTED
HEARING THIS MEME THIS WEEK,
"OH, IT'S THE CULT OF TRUMP,"
THEY TRIED TO SAY HE WAS DUMB,
HE HAD DEMENTIA.
REMEMBER THAT LAST YEAR?
THEY NEEDED TO REMOVE HIM FROM
OFFICE.
LIKE THE CABINET HAD TO BE
ACTIVATED.
DICK MORRIS, YOU'VE SEEN THE --
>>I THINK HIS POLICY IS
CRUCIAL.
BUT I THINK THE THING ABOUT HIS
PERSONALITY THAT IS CAPTURING
PEOPLE IS THAT HE'S CONGRUENT
WITH WHAT PEOPLE WANT.
WE WANT THE PRESIDENT TO GET
STUFF DONE WITHOUT WAFFLING OR
WITH WINDS BLOWING.
AND TRUMP IS A BUILDER.
HE'S A DEVELOPER.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
HE GETS IT BUILT.
AND WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT KOREA OR
THE ECONOMY, THE CRITICS ALL SAY
HE CAN'T DO IT, IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
BUT THEN HE GETS IT DONE.
HE IMPLEMENTS IT.
EVEN AFTER IT'S DONE, THEY STILL
SAY HE DIDN'T DO IT OR IT'LL
COME APART.
AND THAT CREATES A REAL SENSE
THAT THIS GUY IS SOMEONE TO
FOLLOW BECAUSE HE GETS IT DONE.
IT'S THE SAME CONCEPT THAT
INSPIRED REAGAN AND EVEN
CHURCHILL SUPPORTERS, THAT WE
DON'T CARE IF HE LEFT OR RIGHT,
WE LOVE THE WAY HE ACTS, THE WAY
HE GETS IT DONE AND EXPRESSES
OUR INNERMOST DESIRES ABOUT WHAT
THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD DO FOR US.
>> HE'S UNAPOLOGETIC ABOUT HIS
DESIRE AND IMPATIENCE FOR CHANGE
FOR AMERICAN WORKERS.
THAT'S JUST REFRESHING.
YOU'VE BEEN AROUND WASHINGTON
FOR SONG.
IT'S REFRESHING TO HEAR SOMEONE
TODAY.
WHAT DID HE SPEND, LIKE 45
MINUTES WITH ANSWERING QUESTIONS
JUST OUT IN THE DRIVEWAY.
I THOUGHT IT WAS GREAT.
BUT YOU JUST WROTE A PIECE ABOUT
THE SUPPOSED CULT PHENOMENON.
SO TELL US YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
WHERE THE REAL CULT ME  --
>>THE PEOPLE WHO WOULD FOLLOW
SUCH A LEADER ARE MINDLESS,
DELUSIONAL WHACK JOBS.
THERE'S A SENSE HERE, IT'S ONLY
ABOUT 15 SECONDS ON THE GOOGLE
TO FIND NEW YORK TIMES EDITORIAL
LAST WEEK, THE CULT OF TRUMP.
NATIONAL JOURNAL LAST YEAR.
I GET THE IDEA THAT THIS IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
AND WHETHER OUT OF LOYALTY OR
OUT OF FEAR, MANY REPUBLICANS
ARE FALLING INTO LINE.
BUT TO CALL IT A CULT, AND NO
ONE GETS UPSET ABOUT IT.
THEY STILL DON'T QUITE GRASP
TRUMP'S APPEAL.
>> IT'S UNBELIEVABLE TO ME THAT
NOW A YEAR AND A HALF INTO THIS,
HIS NUMBERS ARE GOING UP,
MUELLER'S ARE GOING DOWN.
ALL THE MEASURES THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT.
CONFIDENCE IS UP, A POSSIBLE
DENUCLEARIZED KOREA.
I JUST HAD TO PLAY SOMETHING
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO
LOVE THIS.
LINDSEY GRAHAM TODAY WAS BEING
CRITICIZED FOR ACTUALLY WORKING
WITH TRUMP.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I LIKE THE PRESIDENT.
I TRUST HIM IN TERMS OF TRYING
TO DO THINGS THAT ARE BIG AND
MATTER.
>> BUT PEOPLE SAY THIS IS
TWO-FACED.
WHERE AT THE GRAHAM OF STANDING
UP TO DONALD TRUMP.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> WHEN I WORKED WITH PRESIDENT
OBAMA, AND I DID ON OCCASION, I
WAS A HERO.
NOW WHEN I WORK WITH TRUMP, I'M
TWO-FACED.
I KNOW HOW THE GAME IS PLAYED.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE ME WORKING
WITH TRUMP TO MAKE THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE, I DON'T GIVE A
[BLEEP].
>>THEY'RE TRYING EVERYTHING BUT
NONE OF IT IS STICKING.
I'M TELLING YOU, I THINK THEY'RE
OUT OF POLITICAL AMMO HERE.
CLOSE IT OUT FOR US.
>> I THINK THERE ARE TWO
THINGS.
I THINK FIRST PEOPLE -- THE
DEMOCRATS BET ON IMPEACHMENT.
THEY BET ON RUSSIAGATE.
AND THAT'S FALLING APART AND
THEY HAVE NO B PLAN.
AND SECONDLY ON POLICY, IT'S SO
CLEAR WE'RE OPPOSED TO TRUMP'S
ECONOMY, TRUMP IS HORRIBLE, THAT
WHEN HE ACCOMPLISHES SOMETHING,
THEY CAN'T SHARE THE SPOTLIGHT.
THEY CAN'T SHARE THE CREDIT.
REPUBLICANS COULD SHARE
CLINTON'S CREDIT FOR HEALTHCARE
REFORM AND THE BALANCED BUDGET.
>> THEY'RE FRESH OUT OF IDEAS.
IT'S SHOWING.